we have some good vibes for you courtesy  of jason momoa yes jason speaking of  sexual awakenings  himself is taking his protector of the  deep uh role seriously as he fights for  oceans under threat in real life  partnering with the united nations jason  has officially become the un advocate  for life below the water and while  attending the press conference on a  beach in lisbon portugal jason reacted  to his new title and joked why they  weren't able to arrive by boat to the  event bye everyone take care yay  [Applause]  thank you for waiting it's been quite an  adventure to get here peter thank you  for having me the u.n for having me um  i'm extremely excited it's my first time  on a sailboat we tried to get in but uh  unfortunately  my team couldn't get in of course i  could swim it but  this nice suit isn't waterproof and i  would look very well